bonjour c'est amel bent pour brut le
premier événement je pense que c'est là
c'est important de parler de la
séparation de mes parents donc j'étais
petit j'avais 3 ans donc à l'époque ma
mère à la fuye voilà une relation un
petit peu beaucoup toxiques est plutôt
dangereuse et donc en fait on est parti
en général c'est le papa qui s'en va là
c'est maman qui c'est qui est parti avec
moi et là en fait on a commencé toutes
les deux à vivre une période on va dire
de galère c'est à dire qu'elle n'avait
pas d'appartement donc on a vécu en
foyer on a vécu chez des gens puis c'est
là peut-être dès l'enfance que j'ai
forgé cette mentalité de guerrière que
j'ai aujourd'hui en fait parce que
malheureusement au delà du fait d'être
une enfant de parents séparés divorcés
peu importe je crois que le plus
important c'est ce qui m'est resté c'est
c'est l'impression de ne pas avoir eu
d'enfance en fait parce que quand on se
retrouve seul avec une maman un peu dans
la nature à essayer de s'en sortir
en fait on devient on n'est plus
l'enfant de sa mère on devient son allié
son partenaire évidemment je ne veux pas
et la question n'est pas là mais je
crois que ça m'a rendu tout de suite
j'étais adultes avant l'âge en fait je
pense que le deuxième moment le plus
important de ma vie ça a été ce casting
à la nouvelle star mais évidemment pour
y aller pour y aller j'ai dû j'ai dû
vendre des habits à moi parce que
j'avais pas d'argent pour prendre le
train il y avait plus de place à paris
donc je m'étais inscrite à lille et
maman évidemment elle n'avait pas les
moyens de payer le billet de train donc
donc j'ai vendu des truc à moi genre au
marché aux puces des j'ai vendu des
trucs de 50 centimes en 50 centimes pour
prendre un aller sans retour
aline et j'ai pris ce train est
évidemment j'ai froid dès le retour et
je suis arrivé là bas je suis arrivé là
bas je suis passé devant des prêts
caster et ça je le savais pas et je me
rappelle de 7,2 ce moment de pré casting
ou en fait c'est un mec qui me filmer et
qui me demandait de chanter donc une
chanson ensuite il m'a dit tu peux moins
chanter une deuxième donc j'ai chanté
une deuxième chance et m'a dit toi tu
peux m'en faire une troisième est là moi
je commence à transpirer et je vous
dirai ça et c'est mort si l'on demande
autant c'est que c'est que c'est sûr
il n'est pas certain il est indécis donc
c'est mort ça va se finir par un parent
nom est en fait au bout de la cinquième
chanson que je chante je lui dis mais
c'est qu'est ce qui se passe en fait
c'est normal j'ai plus de chance on en
fait vous chantez là je suis un peu
stressé et me dit non en fait depuis
depuis la première phrase que vous avez
chanté moi j'ai un coup de coeur pour
vous aider put alors en fait je me fais
juste ce qu'il fait a été trop contente
donc qui me dit vous allez passer devant
le jury le vrai jury mais demain j'ai
fait merde j'ai pas d'argent pour être
là demain quoi j'ai pas d'argent pour me
payer un hôtel je sais pas où je vais
dormir je sais pas j'ai pas d'habits
fait surpasser le lendemain j'avais on
avait très dans les rues toute la nuit
pas dormi nettoyer rapidement au mcdo et
habillé comme la veille mais mais
tellement heureuse j'étais tellement
heureuse d'y être donc j'avais peur et
en même temps dès que je me met à
chanter bain j'oublie tout je fais ce
que j'aime et voilà j'ai chanté j'ai
chanté comme j'ai toujours eu l'habitude
de le faire avec tout mon amour et toute
mon émotion
voilà tout ce que j'avais à donner et ça
l'a fait le troisième moment le plus
important de ma vie je pense que c'est
le jour où avec diam's ont décrit ma
philosophie
quand je sors de la nouvelle star en
plus je suis perdante
j'ai la chance d'être repéré par par un
label qui est jive jive records de
l'époque c'est le label d'alicia keys
ping ils viennent me voir à la sortie de
de la demi-finale où je ressort perdante
ils me disent voilà non n'attendaient
que tu perdes on adore on veut
travailler avec toi on me demande avec
qui j'aimerais travailler je dis moi il
ya une artiste qui qui qui qui me fait
rêver en fait parce qu'elle a à la fois
les les mots delà de la chanson
française que j'aime de tout le aznavour
que j'ai pu écouter lubret dupire a fait
et compagnie et en même temps elle a le
côté caché et honnête et sincère de tout
le rap que j'écoute
à ce moment là aussi est à - 2 tm dedans
il ya moyen mais à mon kheriji mca est
chez elle en fait je retrouve tout ce
que tout ce que je veux faire et je dis
je veux je veux je veux rencontrer 7 7 7
femmes en fête et du ok y'a pas de
soucis donc je rencontre diam's et là
elle me dit de quoi tu as envie de
parler
je suis dit bon je sais pas a me dis
c'est quoi tes peurs c'est quoi tes
craintes c'est quoi tes rêves c'est quoi
tes espoirs et est en fait je dis en
fait c'est aussi facile que ça faut
juste que je te dise tout ça me dépasse
et ça que tu dois mettre dans tes
chansons
faut dire la vérité aux gens et je lui
dis bah voila moi moi je suis pas bien
dans ma peau parce que je me trouve je
me trouve pas belle
et puis
g j'ai l'impression que qu'à la télé a
pas beaucoup de gens comme moi j'ai peur
de me sentir différentes
j'ai peur contre juge parce que je suis
une banlieusarde j'ai peur qu'on ne juge
pas ce que je suis une maghrébine j'ai
peur qu'on me juge pas ce que parce que
parce que j'aime autant la râpe que la
variété française j'ai peur qu'on me
juge parce que je suis grosse j'ai dit
ok bah tu sais quoi
on va mettre tout ça dans une chanson
est surtout le principal temps lui de
réussir dans ta vie tu as envie de tout
défoncer et envie de tout niké je dis
bah oui hamdi ben c'est ce qu'on va dire
dans cette chanson et on a co écrit ma
philosophie
ce jour là la première fois qu'on s'est
rencontrés c'est sûr que quand j'arrive
avec ma philosophie est que je chante
pour la première fois à la télé je sais
qu'il est en train de se passer quelque
chose je sais que je le vois même quand
je prends la victoire de la musique et
que à un moment donné je suis là et que
j'ai ma victoire et je dis j'aurais fait
un bisou à toute la courneuve
je me rends bien compte que que je suis
en train de prendre une place en fait
que personne n'avait jamais prise parce
que je suis je suis pas dans l'ès de
l'invisibilité des gens de l'urbain
qu'on monterait pas j'ai en fait j'ai la
visibilité d'une chanteuse de variété
mais avec un avec un background la
stricte le retour on va dire à la
musique avec ce sixième album demain qui
s'appelle pas demain pour rien
justement après la rencontre avec mon
mari j'ai fait quelque chose que je
n'avais jamais osé faire c'était c'est
de me couper de ma musique me couper de
mon métier en fait surtout peut-être
justement parce que j'ai estimé qu'il y
avait autre chose à construire à côté et
qu' il fallait un moment donné que je me
persuader que je me et que je le vivent
ce hamel sans son métier en fait
hamel quand elle n'est pas chanteuse est
ce que c'est vraiment le néant où il se
passe quelque chose quand même dans ma
vie en dehors de ça c'est là que j'ai eu
mes enfants c'est là que j'ai pris le
temps de voyager que j'ai pris le temps
de m'occuper de moi de ma santé de de
sonder un peu ce que tout ce que j'ai
été en dehors de la chanteuse en fait
que j'avais négligé j'avais jamais vu un
dentiste j'avais jamais vu un docteur en
général je j'étais que sur scène ou en
studio tout le temps tout le temps tout
le temps et j'avais jamais pris soin en
fait deux mois et donc j'ai fait tout ça
pendant pendant cinq ans et faire ce
sixième album en fait c'était mais ce
n'était pas sûr
c'était pas sur ça a été un long chemin
un long chemin psychologique et
émotionnel et refaire cet album c'était
me prouver à moi même que je pouvais
être les deux en fait je pouvais être
les trois je pouvais être une femme une
vraie femme qui s'occupe d'elle qui a
conscience de ce qu'elle veut et c'est
je peux être une vraie maman c'est à
dire m'occuper de mes enfants vraiment à
plein temps et et
et pas être un fantôme quelle voix
seulement à la télé ou sur you tube et
je peux être une vraie artiste